joey de nace su primer movimiento para
restringir el uso de armas en eeuu el
presidente anunció medidas para regular
esa práctica ampliamente extendida en la
nación lo hace después de que varios
tiroteos masivos marcarán el inicio de
su mandato
swift éstos queremos tratar las pistolas
modificadas con abrazaderas
estabilizadoras con la seriedad que
merecen una abrazadera estabilizadora
hace que esa pistola sea mucho más
precisa que un mini figura como
resultado es más letal gas grisú
desmovilizó en estados unidos es legal
construir armas caseras son las llamadas
armas fantasma difíciles de rastrear
maiden prevé elevar la dificultad para
conseguirlas y hacer obligatoria la
declaración de antecedentes el
presidente aseguró que tendrá como
prioridad poner fin a la impunidad que
reciben los fabricantes de estos
artefactos en el congreso e instó al
legislativo a prohibir la tenencia de
armas de asalto
también deberíamos prohibir las armas de
asalto y los cargadores de alta
capacidad en este país viajarán
un hombre más unisex mental
durante los 10 años que lo hicimos el
número de tiroteos masivos en realidad
disminuyó e incluso funcionarios
policiales nos han dicho que a veces se
sienten superados en poder de fuego
debido a la tenencia de armas de asalto
el gobierno trabaja también en una ley
de bandera roja que permitiría a los
ciudadanos solicitar a la justicia que
confisque las armas de una persona
considerada peligroso según cifras
oficiales una media de 100 personas
mueren diariamente en el país por armas
de fuego algo que el líder de la casa
blanca calificó como una vergüenza
internacional
bardem pidió al congreso actuar
inmediatamente y prometió utilizar todos
los recursos en sus manos para llevar a
cabo la reforma sin embargo las medidas
de control de armas se enfrentan un
fuerte obstáculo en el senado donde los
republicanos rechazan en bloque estas
restricciones